hey folks what's up happy Friday to
everybody welcome we are doing a
GameSpot live of course destiny to again
cuz it's destiny to week and of course
you know me Eric I don't need an excuse
to play destiny I love the game
glad that everyone's here hope you guys
are having a happy Friday glad you guys
could tune in thanks Slender Man for
subbing I think he said I sub I got you
guys in chat twitch YouTube again thank
you guys for hanging out with us
and today's premise is kind of oh
somebody moved my picture in picture let
me fix that while we talk
the premise of today's stream is as the
titles mentions I like people there are
new guardians out there playing destiny
- that didn't play destiny one that
might not know what to do after they
finished the story
for example Justin hey wold who just
finished our news our leading news
editor just finished story yesterday and
tweeted out saying you know like hey I
finished story what should I do now
so this is kind of geared towards
helping those folks and of course I'll
try to answer as many questions as I can
while we're at it and I'm going to show
you guys some stuff also today that's
new to destiny - something that we've
been waiting for as a feature to come
into the game well you know it was
always a feature that we knew about in
the game is clans so let me show you the
clan GameSpot clan there's our new
banner that Rob handler II made thank
you rob for making this wonderful banner
for us let me get rid of that myself
okay someone broke my game - somehow you
know sometimes people come into your
studio and just change things somehow
everything's working the way
you want it to one day the next day you
come in and it's not the way you thought
it was gonna be all right
boom does that work all right cool
I fixed it blame Tay all right what's up
Lucas later
Rabia anyways game talk clan I think
it's a hundred cap so you know if you're
interested you know there's rewards for
being part of the clan leveling up the
clan you get more rewards for being in
the clan we're gonna do a little video
later on explaining kind of just what
clans are how they work me and John Luke
but this is kind of our start here the
GS games block clan if you guys want to
join obviously you I'm not sure if they
fixed the searchable clan things I'm
bungee Don not yet but GameSpot is there
hopefully you can find it if not you
should tell us and yeah we're gonna
start doing every Tuesday Destiny's
children is a two-parter Tuesdays live
streams with me Rob and John Luke we're
gonna intermix the three of us that
sounds kind of weird but it only be two
of us at a time whereas on Fridays UK
our UK team Lucita more and Dave that
fire team will be playing and posting
like a long play of you know what their
where what they're up to and this will
run for you know a good you know six to
eight weeks so every Tuesday I think our
premise will be like hey the nightfall
reset let's get new members and try to
help people out that's kind of the hope
we'll see that starts next Tuesday
so anyways there's the clans but back to
kind of just talking about stuff you can
do once you finish the game obviously
you can go PvP if you like there is a
reason to do PvP you have milestones
weekly the call to arms quest
essentially that was in destiny one
which was like a weekly quest is back
and it gives you powerful gear from
shacks and powerful gear is awesome
because it scales to your level unlike a
lot of the other legendary engrams that
kind of stop at 265 from the vendor's
you can also get legendary engrams with
those unless you're lucky will only roll
up to
to 70 whereas if you're let's say 275
light this powerful gear is probably
gonna be roughly around that or higher
so that's something you might want to do
obviously nightfall is another thing you
want to consider doing once you know the
story but of course nightfall
requires a certain power level it the
main requirement right now is 240 but
obviously you guys should probably be
higher than that
I heard I've heard some struggles you
know what that might that pip is totally
in the way let me get rid of that sorry
guys
so yeah clan XP now also has powerful
gear which is pretty cool so glad to see
that that's in there that's new on the
the milestones list earn XP and strikes
raids crucible or world activity so
we'll be trying to get that one
obviously another thing you can do of
course our strikes we can take a look at
that obviously you have your strikes
kind of playlist or you can earn a bunch
of stuff and then you have your
nightfall
which will have different varying
modifiers for the week and you generally
will get good good gear from here
sometimes exotic if you're lucky if it's
like testing one other things you can do
obviously or go on two planets if you
haven't unlocked the patrol quests you
can do that through Kade I don't have it
here anymore unfortunately but each
planet has kind of quote quests and
missions that you can do post story
after the campaign some of those lead to
exotics weapons I can show you some like
the might of multitool obvious that my
pro tip here though is with some of
these exotic weapons you kind of want to
wait until your higher power levels so
that you can get a really high level
free exotic but you can still do the
missions just kind of don't turn it in
till later
same with Sturm so the missions are cool
obviously because they gave you free
gear and they're just cool stories you
can also do you know adventures of
course if you need rare gear or upgrade
points like I might do some of these for
upgrade points I don't know what this
dynasty
story leads to I should probably find
out but yeah ultimately you're trying to
increase your power level so that you
can be potentially rate ready if that's
something you want to do or to do trials
obviously but yes so that's kind of
where we're at with that and so I guess
the first thing we can do I showed you
guys a lot of public events yesterday we
can go and why don't we go and do an
adventure or something show you guys
some of that I'm sure you guys have seen
it but that's something we can do
obviously public events is another thing
you can do after story it's a fun
activity for you and your teammates to
do once you've you know kind of finish
the story but yeah if you guys have any
questions or anything like that or good
tips that you guys have learned as well
put those in the chat obviously and I'll
try to get through that as as I can
obviously it's not a decrypt goop I
would just wait to turn in that last
part I think Andrew Alexander asking
quickest way to get to 260 in my opinion
if you have the patience I would just
say just do a lot of public events and
try to trigger those as heroics we
actually did a video yesterday on how to
trigger heroic activities for heroic
public events we can try to do in this
one right now since it's actually active
and show you what I mean if you don't
know what those are yet Andrew Alexander
so we'll try to do that right now let's
see if I can get into this and see if I
can help them out
looks like it's halfway so for this one
this is the cabal excavation what
happens is you want to override this
Lander but in a little bit a ship a
cabal ship is actually gonna fly by and
what you need to do is you need to kill
that ship before the timer essentially
runs out you have about I think two or
three chances to kill them and then once
you kill that ship it's actually going
to trigger the heroic which will then
spawn a big boss so this is a good way
to get more loot especially if you can
make it heroic because heroic gives you
a better chance at more loot so you'll
get like two blues and potentially a
legendary engrams you can get exotic
engrams from this you'll get tokens
obviously there's the ship right there
that I'm talking about the Thresher so
basically you just shoot this guy down
hopefully while hopefully not dying to
other stuff I tend to get shot by other
stuff all the time but yes it looks like
the other people other Guardians here
that I'm with know that we need to shoot
down this pressure he does come around
like I said at least two times if not
three so try to kill him he's gonna come
back in a second
we'll try to kill him and get that done
another thing you can do is there's K
treasure maps but I would kind of save
those too until later but you could do
Kate has two types of treasure maps I'm
sorry he has an EDC treasure map which
has chests that he just tells you where
to get and then there's like a scouting
report which will tell you where chests
are and you want to do that one when
you're on a planet because it lasts it's
a for our buck and only cost climber and
it'll tell you where treasure chests are
and treasure chests are good because
they can give you coins sometimes you
can get legendary engrams out of them
and the more coins you get the more
you'll be able to level up your faction
or the NPC's on the planet so if you get
20 coins
that'll oh oh did he already override
the lander okay so this guy screwed it
up for us you just stood there and
didn't want to kill the ship so you'll
still get a chest from doing public
events which is good but you just have
less like likelihood to get like more
stuff you'll probably just get a coin
maybe one blue whereas if you did it
heroic you probably get two like the
chances of getting two blues is higher
and a chance of getting exotic and
legendary Engram obviously so right now
I have a map triggered for necess a
scouting report so there's a chest here
obviously so we're gonna open that up
just got a coin but again coins are fine
there's another chest right there which
is like really good obviously
so yeah it's a pretty good stuff so
basically for me I just the way I
leveled up quickly just a few 60-plus
was I just did a lot of heroic well I
eventually started doing heroic public
events you don't always get coins so
just be mindful of that we're trying to
do a story aren't we for an adventure
oh the adventure is pretty far away and
I can't access it
but that's fine we can head towards that
direction but yeah I just did a lot of
public events I just scanned the
destinations once I figured out you can
do heroic events I started doing that
and we can actually show you another
really cheeky way to level fast I'll
show it to you guys later in the stream
kind of explain that also if you for
some reason want the picture-in-picture
back I can do it if not we can just
leave it as gameplay today and just
enjoy that I've gone the wrong way
I'm sorry oh I totally went the wrong
way
you can also pick up that stuff right
there the let's just go back I apologize
totally what the wrong way there's it
looks like there's daily challenges too
so it says you know do a loss sector the
tangles
Nessus scavenger if you do those you'll
get I believe two coins each one so a
total of six coins there which is
obviously pretty good but you only need
20 to get and when you turn in 20 coins
to the vendor
they'll usually give you two legendaries
sometimes they'll give you one legendary
and legendary shards but the legendary
shards actually that they give you is
more than if you broke down a legendary
which is like five or six which is
pretty good obviously but yeah we have a
bunch of guides up on YouTube how to get
sturm exotic hand cannon we also have a
bunch of guides written guides that you
guys can check out like which class
might be for you that's also on youtube
if you guys want to check that out
you guys haven't subbed you know
consider subbing so that you guys can
get notified for when we go live for
live streams which is every day at 11
a.m. and also when we put a bug cool
blog contents like and features like the
history of assassin speed which John
Luke and Richard we worked on recently
if you want to learn about where how it
began and where it started at that
feature is up and available for your
viewing pleasure on the youtubes well
yeah we do a bunch of cool stuff Mike
and Jake do reboots we have to lobby on
Wednesdays yeah does this right
legendary equals to 65 cat power gear
power gear equals 270 exhaust greater
than two seven days
not necessarily goop powerful gear
actually scales to your level meaning
that if you're 270 it's that powerful
gear is gonna be at least 270 plus I
thought it was too I thought it was a
265 plus thing but then it actually
isn't oh wow we got personal plan XP I
kind of want to see what that does okay
so it's this got it so yeah we're gonna
do this lost crew adventure which is one
of the things one of the fun things you
can do to get upgrade points here I
wouldn't say this is a fast way though
to get gear so be mindful of that
Fathead gaming asking how do I start a
heroic public event and how do I tell
the difference between heroic and
standard public events all events will
start off as public to just normal
public events what you have to do is
depending on which heroic or sorry which
public events you get it will you have
to trigger the heroic differently so if
you actually want to be Paige we did a
video on how to achieve heroic public
events in that cabal excavation a public
event that we were just at it want what
what we had to do there was kill the
Thresher ship that that was flying
around before we actually finished
holding me like landing
the landing rate and so we didn't do
that so it didn't trigger heroic but if
you do the right things it will trigger
heroic and it'll say hey you've joined a
heroic public event and when you do that
you'll then be able to gain have the
chance to get more loot essentially and
so you can watch that video or we can
also try to do some heroic public events
when we see them or try to trigger
heroic public events when we see them
guess I grind heroic pubs because I'm
almost 265 yeah I mean pretty much it's
the fastest way goob it's not the only
way obviously you can do strikes I did a
strike and and I got really lucky I got
it exotic engrams off of it but that's
obviously just luck but I would say that
if you're looking for speed definitely
go ahead and do her try to trigger as
many heroic public events as you can
some heroic public events are pretty
hard by herself so try to have a fire
team if possible or hope that people are
there I would try to get rid of that one
other guy that's kind of being weird I'm
not trying to sell this game chaos I'm
just trying to help those that are past
the story if you're not into the game
then I get it that's fine
but you don't need to come raining on
everyone else's parade just because
you're not a destiny fan or whatnot or
if you just don't like me in general
that's fine you don't have to watch I
understand I guess thank you for your
comment thanks bad head gaming um for
the question and thanks for going to
potentially watch that video it'll give
you a rundown on how to do those things
and it'll make a lot more sense once you
see them and once you do them and you'll
get you so there's only I believe eight
public events and they each have their
own
special way to trigger the euro so check
that out
it'll be really helpful and hopefully
you get an exotic I've gotten to exotics
from the heroic public events pink one
last night and one yesterday afternoon
so definitely worthwhile but GU about
boof and everyone in town I'll show you
another way so like I said it was kind
of cheeky kind of dirty but if you want
to try it to do it it should work I let
me try to read his name it's IX ze 3 X I
saying
wrap up your vendors you got a war to
coil from it yeah you can get lucky from
the vendors and get a exotic from the
vendor if you're like you're lucky and
oh shoot
and if you're lucky that's awesome I got
lucky one time I got a son shot to 71 so
once you get the vendors max they'll
only give you 265 legendaries it won't
be higher than that but if you're lucky
and get an exotic it can be you know
potentially up to 270 plus I'm currently
playing on a ps4 let's all game yes
none of the tips I'm giving right now
will affect you on Xbox one if you're
playing on xbox
the only difference on ps4 is there's a
weapon exclusive a strike exclusive map
and a crucible exclusive map but all the
tips that have you've been giving so far
or the topics I've been talking about
are in both consoles or on both consoles
Matt Marcille asking I'm new to destiny
because I didn't play destiny 1 what
should I expect from this as opposed to
other FPS games is this okay for
single-player I believe you could solo
this game if you wanted to the game is
definitely more fun with like a fireteam
but that's another story in terms of
what you can expect in the game it's a
very in my piss is my opinion obviously
a very high quality space shooter that
has really sound shooting mechanics if
the weight of the you know the weight of
the shooting the sound of the shooting
they all sound they all feel great in my
opinion again and the story this time
around compared to destiny one is a lot
better in my opinion but there's just a
lot of fun different things that you can
learn about and I think that if you
enjoy FPS games this is a game that I
would recommend trying if you have the
money for eggs sausage McMuffin Araki
professional is always trying to be
trying to be Chazz grace asking is level
20 the current max level yes that's like
what part 1 of 2 if you want to think
about it like that so part 1 is you know
obviously get to level 20 that's max
level and then there's power level which
is based on your gear and you slowly you
slowly level that up as you acquire more
here and to do that there are multiple
ways as mentioned before strikes you got
nightfall you got crucible Oh
a weird jump please mantle thank you
there is a public event happening near
but I kind of want to try to focus on
finishing this so that especially with
these platforms
kind of coming
we can try to go check out that public
event in a second I can try to trigger
it as a heroic hopefully thank you I
just picked it up today
sweet man Marcille I think you'll have a
lot of fun come back hopefully on
another day and share your thoughts oh
crap I totally my legs good thing I have
space so this is glimmer extraction I'll
try to show it to you guys real quick so
what you want to do is what you want to
do is there's a glimmer yeah that thing
what they're hitting there's a little
tool that seems to extract that glimmer
do you need to destroy it's at each
extraction point I want to say there's
been a couple times where somebody
didn't kill the first one but it ended
up being okay because multiple devices
showed up at the end so as long as you
kill all the devices before the timer
goes off you should be good to go and
it'll trigger her oak where you have to
basically protect a big pile of glimmer
and kill a boss boss captain that's
bigger than this excavation
but you'll see in a second these guys
know what they're doing so get back to
that yeah it's a tough one fire Hedgehog
I know it's gonna be tough to wait on
p.a PC it did look good I will say the
advantage will have on PC is you know
you'll have fov sliders you're gonna
have 1080 60 at your disposal 4k at your
disposal if you want which is something
that console players won't have so it's
definitely a trade-off obviously but
hopefully you enjoy yourself I'm happy
that the PC crowd finally gets to get
their hands on destiny I know there was
quite a lot of people and the tractor so
I'm really happy that that group of
players will now have destiny to play
all right so second swimmer device down
one more to go after we finish this one
and we can get back to our adventure
well basically you're you're farming
four gear and it's just about how
efficient you can be to level it if you
want to take it slow that's totally fine
too
these are just some tips to help speed
up your speed up your leveling also I'll
give you another tip about infusing in a
second once we can kind of finish these
two things and focus and show you guys
the menus a bit but it's a pretty good
tip a solid tip that I didn't realize at
first until I kind of like get it a
couple times and then happen to have
that like aha moment kind of curious for
all the Guardians that are in chat if
you know what what classes are you guys
playing you know rep your class I'm
Titan fighting for life pretty much I
mean I had all three characters in d1
but so there's that pilot glimmer
I was mentioning just question where's
your health at my health if I can get
shot it's at the very top that top
middle when you see blue it's because I
have a over shield I have to get a hit
to show you the help again but it's that
white bar right there that goes down
currently we have a kneeling worth
there's the big captain those
so we just have to transmit or transmit
that
the glimmer back so there's a timer
there it's like you got captured
essentially show you guys just a second
so if we stand in here it's like hands
hands maddening the glimmer back and so
you just wait here till fallen as they
come
and protect the glimmer essentially and
as long as you're actually on this point
before the timer runs out and you don't
die you can actually still achieve the
heroic but this one's probably by far
the easiest one it's still a little bit
difficult by yourself because you know
there's a lot of enemies and that
captain could be a pain in the butt if
you're by yourself but I think it's
doable depending on your light level
definitely easier as you mentioned there
you go so heroic done well see if you we
got lucky and maybe streamers luck will
stay exotic now we only got one blue so
that happens sometimes sometimes you get
two blues but you just want to trigger
her oak just to give yourself a better
chance obviously tighten all the way it
says tin 54 we just flip warlock all day
says Jeff surrett let's all game tighten
I like it will you be streaming the raid
next week says Jay Garcia um we are
talking about it we got to see if we can
get enough people raid ready we also do
want to do it so that Callie plaguey who
is our destiny - reviewer this time
around I think Mike did a lot of the
destin'd stuff before but this time
around needs to do the raid to have a
good sense of a full final review so the
hope is that yeah we're gonna try to do
the raid next week I don't know if we'll
have everyone's perspective we might
just do two people in here and then the
rest outside I kind of actually have to
work out some of the logistics with John
Luke but we will definitely try that is
definitely in the cards hopefully
assuming we are all kind of ready - Chaz
grey says warlock Opie and PP my
personal rankings currently and I
haven't PvP that much only enough to
finish that one quest this is from Chaz
is uh I would love it sorry it's hunter
I feel like warlock then Titan but
that's just me obviously it's still
skill based but I feel like having that
dodge reload role for hunter is really
good
and I don't know I just like playing
voidwalker in PvP
so again just put my preference
obviously or my my opinion rather at
games how are you able to move and
address the UI no it's not like wow
I didn't realize there's going to be
this many
that's right there Hobgoblin close call
also the other thing that's interesting
which I'll show you guys in a second
that you guys can play around with it
you haven't noticed is one it's no
longer a disciplined intellect and
strength its mobility resistance and
recovery and because it's that way you
can kind of play around a little bit
more with how you want to expect your
character you can make someone like
super fast and super nimble but then
really weak or like that could get
damaged really easily
so that's something you could play
around with if you want
I got Night Stalker says approach sniper
bro it is ope I'm guessing talk to any
means in PvP would it be shocked though
how many people max in the raid it is
six
you guys want to see other weapons or
anything I can try to show those off I
don't have that many dogs I have some
one of my favorite exotics actually you
can pick up just by playing through the
game it'll become an option that you can
select down the road I think it's to be
honest the best two options are you do
this the graviton Lance which is a pulse
rifle that on kill will cause the enemy
to explode and create like it's kind of
like a void black hole like that pretty
cool and then the other pretty good
exotic is Sun shot which is a hand
cannon that's pretty much kind of got a
fake bring it feel damn I need fried
friends yeah well that was States as
your state the good news is plans are in
the game and hopefully with that and
you'll be able to potentially you know
kind of like queue up and do like a
looking for parade essentially they're
not looking for it but you can queue up
and hope that you know there's a client
that only has five people with us to do
the raid or you can always I'm sure
they're still gonna be sites and things
like bungee net that will have the like
looking for group essentially how
quickly replaced are the pre-order
weapons if you're talking about cold
heart you get cold heart after you beat
the campaign which comes at 2:15 and if
you like that beam weapon and hard to
lose you can infuse it if you want to
obviously I don't have it right now I'm
not using it but can you show us the arc
subclassing and go over the skill tree
so Jerry Garcia sure it's pretty similar
to old striker you know you got
flashbang grenade the grenades are the
same pulse grenade lightning green I
like lightning grenade then you have the
the new third ability which is timing
barricade or rallying barricade this
creates a huge barricade and when they
walk through it they kind of get hurt
enemies get hurt and if it's the AI they
get like slightly blinded I believe and
then this
rallying barricade do I have to actually
oh I actually have to unlock that I'm
not gonna unlock that on this this one
but yeah you could use either one then
you have high-lift strafe jump and
catapult lift again I just haven't
leveled these coz points obviously then
you have frontal assaults reversal
knockout and trampled so and then you
got 7i seismic spent that seismic strike
aftershocks double grenade and or sorry
is this increase the duration and
additional grand yeah and you leave like
kind of like a static field behind so
that was an adventure oh here here's the
kind of pro tip so high but I can't
really show it to you right now but
hypothetically let's say damn I don't
have like a lower end right put them all
in the bank okay so let's say I have
these right actually I could do it for
you guys so an interesting thing about
infusing exotics is that exotics have
this kind of like five defense legendary
modifier on top of the void melee
ability to recharge faster but it has
the +5 defense right same with weapons
weapons have a +5 attack so the
interesting thing is let's say these are
244 right and you're infusing infusing
normally brings it up to the same light
as the thing you're infusing it to
however with an exotic because it has
this +5 damage or defense modifier it's
gonna actually net five more so if I do
this right it's gonna become 269 or
should become 269 if my math is right
boom see 269 so that's a little tip to
kind of get like your exotics even
higher I guess or to infuse your exotics
to kind of pull your light power level
higher so you can do that or maybe you
have an exotic that you don't think
you're going to use but you want to make
sure that your next infusion is like
even higher would be to you know take
I don't have another low and exotic do i
yeah I 249 so if I wanted to use these
to then infuse you know these purple
gloves let's say I'd want to try to pull
this to 272 then make this like 270 if
that makes sense so that's just a little
infusion tip if that makes sense
hopefully it did alrighty let's look at
our destination map destination map all
right you know what I'm just gonna show
it to you guys now
yeah goob so exotics have an inherent +5
armor or +5 damage so when you're
infusing you should actually look at
what you're infusing and just add 5 to
that and that's what it is
what's up Bela how are you doing
alright so now I'm gonna talk about
something cheeky as I mentioned earlier
that you can do and has been discovered
in destiny too it's essentially almost
like having a loot cave again what
you're gonna need to do is you're gonna
need to pick necess when you after you
pick necess you're gonna want to go to
Exodus black so I'm just going to show
that actually I was already there I
don't know why I did that
all right so
all right cool all right so again just
really briefly sorry just to explain all
right so the destiny to Luke cave is
kind of back to do so to get to this
destiny to Luke cave we're gonna need to
go to Nessus obviously and then you need
to fly to exodus black alright cool
when you get to exodus black we're gonna
head on over here might as well get your
Sparrow out assuming you have it you
don't you don't necessarily need to have
a sparrow to do this but it's a little
bit faster if you do it with a sparrow
so you're gonna go through this cave
which I'm kind of dubbing the loot cave
whoops so you're gonna
not get shot by these guys you're gonna
go through here and you're gonna end up
in this other cave which you can also
sum its peril in and we're gonna
continue through this cave
and we're gonna essentially ride over
yonder and then we're gonna keep going
through the cave and then we're gonna
keep going until we get to this platform
which is here in the top right-hand
corner back home maite
whoa oh yeah that's right sorry so after
you get teleported you're gonna run this
way and we're gonna go through that
portal
I believe I actually could have grabbed
the chest just now when we ran through
it the first time but we're gonna run
through this portal and get teleported
here here's those jerks that were
shooting me earlier go ahead get rid of
them but you don't have to deal with
them they'll show up every now and then
so now I happen to have the Nessus
scouting map consumable open but now you
can grab this chest and the reason why
this is kind of the loot cave is because
you grab this chest you'll get a token
sometimes you'll get legendary engrams
sometimes you'll get a blue but anyways
after you do that you're gonna run back
this way can't summon our vehicle there
I think we can summon it back here let
me try one yeah
summon your Sparrow again
and you're gonna ride through the cave
and you're gonna hop off go back to that
platform
I should have my mind a multi-tool out
it actually helps if you want to speed
it up by adding or changing your armor
pieces to mobility but essentially
you're gonna keep run in here and
basically you're just rinse and
repeating so basically you can keep
farming this chest every time now if you
don't have the necessary report there
are like multiple spots where the
treasure chest can be but my suggestion
would just be to have the scouting
report which you can buy from Kate so
basically you can just keep farming
coins which you can give to the vendor
or if you get lucky you'll get legendary
engrams so some of your sparrow again
and then we're gonna get through the
chamber of sky cave here pop off our
sparrow and just rinse and repeat so
yeah this is basically the Destiny - I
guess new loot cave and I'm gonna try a
couple more times and just so we can see
if we get a legendary Engram obviously
you know it doesn't always happen but
one can hope these ones for some reason
this chest just will keep respawning and
so it's like unlimited of chests I guess
if you want to do this now this is a
little mind-numbing
and it's definitely not for everybody so
I understand but if you want to level up
fast this is a decent way to do it
because you're gonna get blues
or Purple's potentially so sometimes
it's back here as the map oh sorry it's
through this alley here so something
that's why this it really helps to have
the map it's only five thousand glimmer
to have the map pick that loot up no
legendary Engram yet but that's okay
we're just gonna run back out again like
I said to make this faster if you have a
mida multi-tool that'll help you run
faster obviously cuz that's just the
perk if you have higher mobility gear
that's gonna help you but basically this
is the destiny to loot cave the new loot
cave so do this at your own risk
obviously that's you know they're
probably gonna patch it I would assume
at some point but you know enjoy if you
want to if you don't that's fine too as
mentioned we have other ways and tips
that we've given you to kind of find
ways to farm like thorough public events
but this way basically just running a
loop
all righty so let's try one more time
and see if we get a legendary if not
we're gonna move on chess can sometimes
be there there's like multiple spots
where you'll spawn so obviously as
mentioned before there you go legendary
in game
it took us about five tries but hey what
was that really in time like a couple
minutes so yeah pretty awesome I guess
if you need to get gear or if you need a
farm tokens you know just run this loop
on exes black in this cave and I hope
you enjoy it
I just muscle-memory
did it again so I guess we might as well
just do it this last time and then we're
gonna destination out of here to do
something else so pretty cool I mean if
I could say that you got one every one
in five that would be pretty awesome but
I don't think that's gonna be the case
also I'm not sure I haven't done this
chest enough but just don't be shocked
if for some reason you don't get a coin
because I've looted chests and not
gotten coins before also I'm not
actually sure if you can get exotics
from this chest so if anyone finds out
and gets an exotic from doing this
method please hit me up tell me your
your findings
not around it's definitely in here
though just got find it
probably like could be up above
sometimes it can be behind or like on
this ledge
sometimes just back there let's see if
it's up top it'd be hilarious if it's
not working anymore
no chest right now
that's interesting should be the first
time we don't see it that our my
scouting report ran out but I don't
think that's possible
that is weird now I'm actually curious
like if it like changed some oh there it
is I don't know why the scouting report
map didn't show it but uh just look all
around obviously this is another spot so
there's always gonna be a chest that
time only a coin but you guys get the
point so let's get on out of here all
right looks like this public events
gonna start so might as well just do
that show that again level of gaming why
does a sword need ammo it's a sword well
you know it's got a it's got a show
somewhere sorry if I missed some chat
showing off that off but yeah KTM 192k
IKEA wat Eric what activities give you
the most legendary shards besides I'm
assuming the nightfall initial asked for
that question
Titan all the way nice i would say
heroic public events would be a good way
potentially but legendary shards
actually you know what that's not true
necessarily I would just farm coins and
break all I'm not gonna get that because
I think I didn't do anything
it's not like that oh wait let me have
it
cool oh that was uh okay so this is a
new one this is the ether servitor what
you have to do for this one is kill all
the baby servitors that he spawns which
is like right there we got to get on it
right now cuz if he consumes it it's
it's over all right we got it so the
next one is harder because he spawns
three I would say though to get
legendary shards really fast just level
up the rep with your vendors which takes
20 of the planetary coins every 20
usually leads to two legendaries or a at
least a legendary and legendary start
sometimes that's actually better if
you're action after a legendary shards
because they give 5 to 6 instead of a
legendary which as mentioned before is
which is better than
I think we did it yeah so we triggered
the hero which is good
sorry I got caught up there but yeah
sometimes they give you five to six
which is better than you just breaking
down a legendary which will only give
you three so that is actually the
fastest way to get legendary cards in my
opinion so by doing uh by doing you know
heroic public events or farming even
that chest I just mentioned that would
probably be the fastest way because we
just want to get twenty coins as fast as
you can and then turn those in and then
break down what the things you don't
want or hope that you only get one
legendary and legendary charts obviously
you guys want to stock up legendary
shards because there is here next week
for some reason I thought you'd show up
this week but the Destiny to schedule
more or less is out now Bungie tweeted
that out yesterday in their reports and
so if you're curious what's the next
week's nightfall is or when the rate is
that information is all out there now so
whoo-whee Oh boom you get a coin also
another decent way to get coins is it
seems like there's daily challenges on
the planets so if you do those
challenges right there on the the
right-hand side you get two coins I
believe for each one so if I picked up
more data lattice I think I should get
two more points if you have a lot of
time and you're not bothered by doing a
grindy grind I would do that chest the
loot cave chest Brian that I just showed
you guys
hey bro says golden glider what's up man
how are you doing what are the other
challenges lost sector entangle we can
do a loss sector lost sectors are
another thing you could do they're like
kind of like mini dungeons and the cool
thing
the cool thing about lost sectors is you
get two coins for that so they're pretty
worth while but they're they take a
little longer so sorry I'm like I need
GPS clearly so I'll make sure we're
going the right way they take a little
bit longer but you know some people
enjoy kind of like that dungeon feel so
level of gaming I kind of explained what
the semi-new loot cave is there's a
chest that you can kind of infinitely
run I'd say it's about you know 30 to 45
seconds go around and you'll get a chest
each time we got a legendary Engram on
our fifth chest but otherwise you're
probably just gonna get coins again to
reiterate I do not know if you can get
exotics out of there because I haven't
actually formed that loot cave those the
first time I've done it so
MJ Brown 3 the loot cave is on Exodus
black I don't think you can actually DVR
back in twitch but if you watch our
YouTube livestream there is a there's
the ability for you to kind of scrub
back and PVR back to when I talk about
the week cave you'll see me kind of
going through the same area like over
and over so that that part is where I
more or less explain it so it was here
on excess black where is a lost sector
there's only one I guess so I don't over
there sorry to the I think that's Korean
name that I cannot read but he asked is
public events totally random or happens
at certain times they happen at a
certain time but the beauty of what
destiny 2 has compared to destiny 1 is
that not alone no longer do you have to
use destiny public event tracker which
was a website which was kind of accurate
but oh shoot sorry hold on these decks
won't let me kind of
just be real quick but the good thing as
mentioned is that now oh I passed a law
sector you can check your destinations
and you can check each planet this is
what I do for heroic events you can see
that that one's gonna happen in about
four minutes so maybe that's not gonna
be soon enough for you you can look you
know they're there on the map
essentially and they tell you how long
they're gonna be from happening so use
that as your your kind of guide I'm
gonna pick up this data lattice because
there's a challenge today and I want to
show you guys that you can get those
coins that way we're gonna do a
challenge because we need like what X
percent won't show right now we need to
gather ten so we've only gathered four
can you replace or emissions a sort of
Jason X 440 with meditations I believe
is was called with iCore array she kind
of gives you the ability to redo some of
that stuff I haven't actually tried it
so I can't speak in depth about it
unfortunately but I believe there is a
way
so now we're in a loss sector which like
as mentioned is more or less like having
a dungeon
there's no minions there's a kind of
boss guy that's gives you essentially a
key to a chest that you get at the very
end which as mentioned again have
usually two coins
yeah you can also re-watch the VOD on
Twitch later it's just that if you're
trying to watch what I said about the
Luque now the only two ways
the only two ways currently is to either
watch on gamespot comm and DVR back from
there or watch on
so this is the boss in this law sector
Hydra doing his Michael Jackson like
back step in trying to find he'll
probably lose
friend
is on the run
try to kill me Laurie something more
stuff
all right so we got the code here's the
said chest that you get at the end so
there I got oh so I did so the reason
why I got four coins just not to mislead
you guys is they got to from finishing
the daily challenge for the planet which
is that first one and then I got to from
the chest for completing the lost sector
so that's why we got what we got
I'm gonna finish the first part of the
data the data lace I always say that
wrong when do you recommend get the
exotics from the quests as Sylvester
Cano I would say try to power like try
to get your power level as high as you
can
the higher the better if you don't have
the patience for that then just that
whenever you get your power level to the
highest because I saw some of my friends
getting to 85 my toes because they
waited till they're like 269 ish or 270
but if you don't have the patience
that's totally fine I think when I got
sturm I was only like two maybe 250 ish
I just missed in a public event but yeah
I guess daily challenges is another good
way I kind of showed some people that
were here yesterday this little farming
run I by the scouting report for necess
and then I just kind of like Sparrow
around and pick up treasure chests for
coins there's like about five or six
chests in just this small area of extra
splash that you can get sometimes you
get shaders sometimes you can get a
legendary Engram but yeah we're still
after the
data the data stuff for the challenge
which we need for Mauro
but that stuff is also pretty prevalent
around this area I should be on my
Sparrow that's like kind of like a tip
just try not to get off your Sparrow
unless this one
yeah sometimes you don't get a coin it
happens there's another chest so you
know or not how many coins do I have I
feel like when I have like 30 plus it
gets a lot slower I have 45 yeah okay
that's reasonable
now in the loot cave thing we did we
always got a coin so I don't actually
know I thought there was but it was
alight I was tricked
well yeah that seems like another good
way to get some easy coins and just kind
of do the whoa the daily challenges on
each planet they're pretty
straightforward like kill X fuel loss
sector pick this up and as mentioned
earlier try to unlock the trolls the
thing you can do patrols while you're
doing the challenge is
this is definitely not infinite warfare
in the human if anything caught World
War two is about to borrow from destiny
and they're gonna have a social space
I'm gonna hold out for my des and
raction racking is a little bit harder
because in unifiers Sturm and Maite our
solar bowl I haven't checked the IO one
to see if there's an exotic for that if
someone knows if there is they can tell
me here empty chests what the f yeah it
happens that sometimes you can come up
empty it's very possible it happened to
me a lot yesterday too
oh he's just trying to have fun oh yeah
that's fine he might be trolling it
happens but he got me to kind of talk
strife X still farming uh yeah just
trying to show off different things that
you could do post story because I know
someone as some of my co-workers I see I
didn't get anything from that either but
I'm guessing we're getting rewards
progression rewards deer yep just trying
to show off different things you can do
when you're doing the story especially
if you weren't a player from Dustin one
had a lot of co-workers just finished
finishing up story yesterday kind of
asking you know hey what should I do
I was like hey we could kind of Center a
stream around things that you know you
could do in destiny to after you know
I'm sorry so hopefully the stream so far
has been helpful for you guys and I
appreciate all you guys hanging out
chatting asking questions
you know repping your your subclass or
your classes rather than out your
subclasses it's been a fun time it's
been a fun Friday definitely blessed and
fortunate to be able to play destiny to
here on stream with you guys and
enjoy your guys's company we are alive
every day at 11 a.m. so come stop by
every Tuesday we're gonna be streaming
destiny too from now on
and then we're still gonna do our
various other games game releases maybe
some other fun stuff that people get
into how do you see daily challenges you
just kind of hold down the middle button
on my playstation it's that a kind of
black pad in the middle that's how you
see the daily challenges for the planet
sometimes you have some UI stuff that
might be on the right-hand side so don't
panic if you don't see anything you know
what after we finished the the daily
challenge we should maybe go turning
points because we haven't gotten any
posts there might be a cap i just opened
about four or five chests nope no coins
and I'm at 45 I don't know if there's
actually cap maybe someone in chat knows
it'd be nice in someone in chat it's all
me high-value targets oh he loves got it
high-value targets also drop coins so
you could you know conceive what we'd
kill those guys under CM
Rep that clan yep don't forget clans
stuff finally is out today in the game
you have a games block plan you're
looking to join a clan that is option
for you
seems like no one is here right now
because I have basically all the chess
timers looks like a heroic event might
be happening soon
looks like the VEX one
again if you guys are keen to learn
about how to trigger those four rope
public events we did post up a video
yesterday night that tells you how to do
those it's pretty short I try to keep it
pretty short so that you guys into the
point so that you guys could just
understand the general premise of how
those things work this has been a real
dry run of coins does anyone know if
there is a 45 Kappa limit on coins I
don't know why 45 would be a number
though that seems kind of all right well
it's not because we just gained two from
doing a public event but we haven't
gotten one out of a chest and a pretty
long time so we're just gonna head on
over and spend 20 coins see how it goes
I actually should be spending these
coins on my I'm making another Titan so
that I can get more gear that way why
should be spending it on him so that he
could get a head head up because we can
get 182 well here you go you turn in rep
as mentioned every 20 coins are gonna
get an Ingram I'm maxed out on my
vendors 265 the only thing I could get
lucky on potentially is maybe getting a
exotic we didn't but see there's two to
legendaries I almost prefer personally
to get shards and a legendary now but
that went to the post it totally went to
the post anyways I was gonna
double-check that there 265 but almost
positive they are so nothing let's see
there we just get rid of some stuff so
we can make some space what sounds weird
I haven't seen any 265 Blues yet I maybe
I have to be even higher level yeah
all right let's go see if the coins are
fixed and now a little bit a little coin
situation here
we're running dry on those chests there
for a hot minute I didn't do that public
event two in a second
but yeah you can also there's a watch a
minute Oh back
that's a good little captain
[Music]
definitely gonna get four
I think I think in certain cases you're
always gonna get something because they
have to but I don't know about chess so
we're kind of testing that theory right
now like I mentioned before when I
personally hit like around 35 before it
likes felt like I was not getting coins
anymore but again that could have just
been bad rng but we did open I've like
five to seven chests and we didn't get a
coin there we go we're back
this is another thing you could do we
could check out another planet we
haven't really done that huh I'm just
wanting to make sure that this coin
thing is kind of accurate and this it'll
give you guys information to you alright
we got a coin so I would say when you
have you know like close to 35 or 40
coins I would start to maybe consider
turning some in because now we're
getting coins all day again so if you're
doing that loot cave thing you might
want to go spend some or if you don't
care about coins game be like chill bra
you're recognizing that dude we're
supposed to be friends and in town
I should really be almost Baro but with
Maya I feel pretty quick alright we'll
go do this alright it's gonna be a lot
harder by myself to trigger her
essentially there's three of these pads
that get summoned eventually and you
have to not only hold off the vex from
going into essentially the confluence
but you also have to hold these to a
hundred now apparently having two people
on the pad is pretty ideal sometimes two
pads are up at one time but essentially
we have to stop these guys from getting
into there and also pad probably gonna
get overrun at some point
this is why you want a fire team right
pad number one is done I'm gonna get off
that guy I believe if you let too many
in it won't let you trigger the Hiroki
there so you see there's a 10 out of 10
at the bottom so you don't want to make
sure that you're keeping it you know as
high as possible Eric have you tried to
see if that em if you get more XP from
10 coins at once compared to one at a
time I have not actually done the math
on that but I have to assume there's got
to be a benefit from turning in multiple
versus
turning my head
oh wait there should be another pad
right now they not finish the first pack
no did maybe it's a time thing
well there it is speak of the devil this
is gonna be really hard to like defend
the conquest while holding this
I can't actually see it's like gassy
asthma and this one's really kind of
so we are a lost progression
yeah someone just teleported into it
like I can't I can't watch it both from
here and at a level 20 apparently
doesn't want to do this event
another guy's trying to tell with you
right now
oh yeah we lost percentage right we had
to have yeah I hold this by myself it's
pretty good I mean it's definitely
doable it's just really tediously
annoying
the last spot the last spot will be
easier to hold
all right we're nine to ten we're okay
if I can stop this guy
I think we'll be okay maybe
okay
choice might even die still barricade is
awkward
I don't even know if I could do it
anymore actually because I have enough
time and working
it is what it is
well couldn't do it couldn't do it her
okay it's too hard by yourself what is
the most powerful weapon in destiny - I
think it's too early to tell did all the
chests on this side alright we'll make a
little bit of a run here in fact this
way so we showed off the adventures we
showed off public events who showed off
a lost sector throw it off some daily
challenges and showed off the blue cave
goat off a priority target or a
high-value target there's still night
balls obviously I didn't do a strike
that's gonna take too long at this at
this rate but strikes are pretty cool
there's five of them six if you're our
PlayStation and so far the ones I've
done have been pretty good I like them
more than the original destiny but
because there's just more involved
there's more stuff you're doing the
bosses are a little bit more complex
[Applause]
sir chest that I don't know where was it
the same chest that I just picked up I
guess that's the same one I just picked
up cool oh it's up there why is you why
use a grenade on that harpy though oh
I'm just trying to throw a grenade that
way to like keep them away from the
conflux if I'm remembering the situation
I'm talking about it wasn't a great
night though I wasn't I wasn't too
thrilled with it sometimes you panic
[ __ ] happens looks like it's pretty dry
here now so do you need to see the floor
finish the story you see the daily
challenges that I'm actually not sure of
Magnus McCloud I don't recall checking
for the for the daily challenges I could
do that on another character though I
believe my other characters on Nessus so
we could do that or maybe someone in
chat knows already so kind of avoid
alrighty so maybe we just do a strike
you guys want what do you guys want to
see that would be beneficial to you guys
for post stories stuff now that we're
kind of at where we're at because I
didn't show you guys kind of a bunch of
stuff that you could do he's still
flying fist of havoc like when you jump
up and come down an angle not diagnose I
don't think that exists anymore
I forgot exactly what the name for that
was
one person same strike Jesse the worm
that's from above Thank You MJ Brown
that was it fluffy fish also saying
strike okay oh let me kill this
high-value target real quick right
around here it's the captain just kill
him really quick and then we'll go do a
strike okay is there plenty to do solo
after campaign yeah I soloed all my
power level to 270 but mostly by myself
or with people that were just out in
public so it's very solo Bowl if you
want to do it
now the only hard part to solo will be
the raid and the nightfall that you'll
probably want a group for obviously but
everything else you can do solo you
would like see a chest so I'm gonna go
go where did it go I totally said chest
do we we all saw it right
all right so it seems like that sweet
spot number as mentioned before is like
when you're getting close to 40 you
probably want to start spending some
point it really felt like I wasn't
getting coins anymore
anyways another nice feature quality of
life featured listening to is you can go
to destinations and just queue up for a
strike without actually having to go to
orbit so let's just keep up first right
I gonna admit the first word there Psalm
in almost has do you oh it's do you
there you go do you recommend buying
this game
it depends depends on what kind of games
you like I think that if you're into FPS
games that have you know a pretty solid
story a good experience if you're in a
shooting mechanics I think this is a
solid first-person shooter with again
pretty decent story and a lot to do
after that some might see that as
grinding though so if you're not really
big on grinding things or like grinding
quests or going grinding heroic events
and things like public events like that
this might not be for you but for me you
know I like the camaraderie of destiny
to and destiny you know I have my old
clan mates coming back playing with them
is a blast obviously and I enjoy the
raids a lot the raids are a huge thing
for me personally coming from a person
that has played like World of Warcraft
lineage to games like that
so yeah that's just me though you you
have to you have to choose for yourself
though if those are some of the things
you think you'd like to do if not then I
would not recommend this game for you so
I'm not trying to sell this game on
anyone
that's just my poop's I was like do I
have a solar yeah you have solar you
dummy
trying to just mix up my elements here
for the
and all these guys are waiting
so this is a this is a pretty fun one
the boss is like a sniper guy
I eventually think doesn't snipe anymore
so he has multiple phases every car now
actually I'm in st. the holes now he
doesn't spike yo you'll see him in a
second and we'll show you the boss
mechanic this is also doing that
probably for this week
again this is just my opinion it's not
like being swatch opinion it's my
personal opinion so take it with a grain
of salt obviously I have no power
and I forgot like after not using the
Maite for so on it's like you got to put
that hat on their head
that's how you get head shots already
it's go dump this ball on Twitch Ravager
here he's got it
can you still use bubble as tightening
says ask random person yes the bubble
still exists it just doesn't have all
the perch that it used to like weapons
of light or blessings of life but the
bubble still exists it is in the game it
is actually in the top part of the
septum--ah tree which I can show you
Enzo gave him saying I'm 312 on my tiny
idea
find it a little bit hard to believe but
if you are Congrats it was such a like
specific number that it like almost
sells me I said you might be through 12
but I have this feeling
it's possible if he's been playing all
day gratz if you're their level three
swallows oh yeah I'll show it to you
real quick random person oops
so class the bubbles right here Ward
have gone say yep still doable I was
going sort of the right way
Jesse the worm yeah I mean like I'm sure
we'll have a higher level when the
expansion comes out but I don't know I
mean I'm fine with it because there's
just more content for me to play now I
know that not everyone has been a DLC
but hey if you're gonna spend
potentially I don't know 15 to 20 hours
or you know 10 hours whatever it is if
that's worth 20 bucks to you that's
worth it
right you want to save a little bit of
money and you know you're gonna play the
expansions then just buy the digital
deluxe or whatever that saves you five
bucks on each expansion 10 and old I
don't even know get to kill this [ __ ]
I guess they are at this scenario
but that's a total ripoff
I mean again personal opinion that $20
is worth it to me I'm fine with it now
not everyone's fine with it I get it but
you can also have people that buy
microtransactions so you know you know
that I think that destiny - alone is
there's a lot of stuff to do
well it's tough to play legend Aryan
ground let's go
unless I have noticed that somehow and
my pre-order packs aren't working in
tips
I missed I guess rheic splain the
question is it possible to get the mitis
or the racking exotic from dropped
exotic on the ground i don't know i
don't think so i would assume not
because they're like quest specific I
never saw it in the things that you
could get dropped when I cycled through
products
rate is out next week I'll prep
it's cool he somehow killed me after
death it was like martyrdom or felt like
martyrdom
Kyle we might be able to do the stream
of the rage we're still working out the
details on that place stay tuned
if it happens it will happen after
[Music]
you got sniped I got sniped by Rockets
man well I might have died to this ion
but ultimately I got hit by rockets
this guy's crazy he's going in he says
my art staff is good enough to destroy a
tank
wise dude over here
there we're crazy - no let me have the
glory
well thank you Henry day yes I probably
got snow camo Midwest says I was a d1
player built at $3,500 PC got a wait
long as hell for the PC version yeah
fortunately
Jesse the worm enough with the sucking
up they're not where they're not
watching again I told you take it with a
grain of salt it's my opinion that's I'm
fine with it so are a lot of people
apparently and there's some people that
aren't fine with it I get that I totally
understand if that if you're worried
about that whole situation and not
wanting to you know pay for DLC just
don't buy the game then that's all right
there are a lot of quality games out
this year that you could play Legend of
Zelda back game will take you 75 hours
if you have a switch go play that if you
have if you have a switch Sonic for $20
that was great
kind of think of all the yet there's so
many good things that came out this this
year from ps4 go play neo that was a
great game if you like Dark Souls you
like games persona 5 just to name a few
I can't that guy's smart he's a
music ornately I'm sure of my pain I'm
actually not huge on the grenade
launchers I just I don't like that you
have to mostly direct hit with them
instead of bouncing them I don't know
maybe I'm just serious or like Coldplay
later Jesse the worm I do appreciate
your thoughts it's fair guys are
entitled to what you want to say what's
the best heavy weapon for the nightfall
asking Henry Kia I haven't actually done
the night poll I've been waiting for
some friends to catch up
mark Lopez says ELC is not a problem I
just want to make there if I'm buying
the bundle if that is all of it that's
fair I don't think they necessarily plan
on rise of iron necessarily but the way
I look at it it's like the same way with
Diablo 3 I feel like the the necro was
like a way to stall and buy time for the
next game so I feel like destiny 2
wasn't ready yet and they probably were
then told like hey we need it we need to
keep you know having content out so that
the you know the players have something
to play and so
we ended up with the right buyer fine
great
so he now assignments from his little
sniper leg and in order to get him off
the ledge we essentially have to carry a
ball that will then destroy his power
and right now he is immune
we cannot damage him but I do believe
you can shoot hashtag salts
I didn't unimpressed with your accuracy
with the controller that's fine I've
been playing a lot lately and you know
sometimes you just aren't in the zone as
much so I don't have adderall on me you
can't feel like a professional Cod
player and I kind of want to know it
could actually like how much
I'd be funny like case-study like
comparison
a person that is in a pro player that
you know he plays you know a competitive
yes without adderall and then all of a
sudden
but then all of a sudden you try what
it's like to see if he did take adderall
if he's so he's like way more head shots
or if his skill level goes up
like you've gone pretty nice women over
that
very hard on that call this thing - I
have more shields yeah that's the one
thing about the night ball though you
want to make sure that your fire team
has a good oh yeah he calls it a ship
doesn't know he calls it backup feel
like there was a ship at one point
though I remember doing this with
chastity man you Couture the other day
did I not work why did I not get it all
over to you
yeah so he stopped sniping
we got them so that's a strike another
activity you could do if you're done
with a story you can also do them during
the story I think you unlock from that
if I recall correctly you get Vanguard
tokens engrams sometimes you get
legendary sometimes you get exotic if
you're lucky but yeah you're gonna hate
throwing is perfect
the first one is bad the second was
pretty good yeah
Enzo gaming can you tell me what to do I
wasn't giving my sword or cold heart
when finishing the campaign that's
actually really interesting I'm assuming
you're in the right place to try to
receive those things if you're having
that problem I haven't had that occur
there have been a couple bugs so I
unfortunately don't know what to tell
you there Enzo gaming I do feel bad
that's that's happening to you I hope
that you get it is that the might of
mini tool the SMG was the might of mini
tool the Scout is obviously the might a
multi-tool but that's gonna wrap up our
stream today really appreciate you guys
all hanging out tuning in just trying to
help enlighten as many people that have
just be campaign or the story on all the
stuff you can do the various things you
can do I'm sure there's much more that
I'm like I might have missed but of
course there's also the Kade Maps which
there's you buy five of that you can buy
five of these and once a week I believe
and those will sometimes have legendary
engrams in them as well so yeah
definitely get those from Kade but yeah
that's about it
Joshua and can you talk louder hopefully
this is loud enough because we're out
chewing but that's that we'll see you
guys next week monday 11:00 a.m. we'll
be live-streaming again I don't recall
the game off the top of my head but
we'll figure it out Tuesday Destiny's
children obviously I think next week
will probably be me and John Luke to
start and also just don't forget destiny
children today with a long play series
with two more Lucy and Dave in the UK
and don't forget clans are also out so
if you're fiend in may be needing clan
games wat clan is available I'm show
that real quick without me cuz the
[ __ ] the flag there we are will be
leveling and progressing that so
all cool things hope you guys are
enjoying the game may be interested in
the game may be interested in picking
that up we have a bunch of guy content
on YouTube as well as the site so stay
tuned to all those things hit that
subscribe button hit that ball button
really appreciate you guys all hanging
out doing your thing giving me knowledge
and also listening appreciate it until
next time guys
by